binnenkort wordt er 1 debat hier in het
tweede kamer georganiseerd over de toekomst van netcar
en werkgelegenheid in de regio in de provincie Limburg
heel belangrijk
eind februari
was ik bij de ondernemingsraad en werknemers
van netcar om met hen in gesprek te gaan
over de toekomst van hun bedrijf
sp heeft heel lang aandacht gevraagd voor de
toekomst van netcar en werkgelegenheid
in Limburg en tot voor kort
lukt het niet om daar 1 meerderheid voor de wat voor
te krijgen nu wel
pure winst heel goed
ik roep iedereen op
als het de bad hier in de
tweede kamer wordt gevoerd over netca
en de toekomst voor werkgelegenheid in Limburg
om daarbij aanwezig te zijn op de publieke tribune
kom hierheen en dan gaan we voor zorgen dat alle andere
politiepartijen
zich ook zo gaan inzetten voor werkgelegenheid
in regio Limburg
als de s p doet